صوره من داخل ثاني اكبر مشافي العلاج
الكيميائي والاشعاعي لمرضى السرطان
بالسودان
اوجاع المرضى واهات الاجساد التي تملكها
المرض العضال ازدادت بعد الحرب والسبب نقص
الادويه والضغط على المستشفى بسبب نزوح
مرضى السرطان الى ولايه الجزيره واقع تسبب
في ندره بعض الادويه وزياده اسعار الجرعات
في السوق السوداء هكذا يقول البعض
ولدنا
وقاعدين بس منتظرين عليه الله ثاني
جرعات مافي كملان نهائيا خالص لكن
مليون الواحده
مؤشرات الضغط على المستشفى بدت واضحه بسبب
خروج نحو 30 مستشفى بالخرطوم عن الخدمه
الامر الذي افرز تحديات صعبه في الامداد
الدوائي وبعض المعينات كاوعيه حفظ الدم
نزح اعداد كبيره جدا من المرضى في اتجاه
ولايه الجزيره في اتجاه المعهد القومي
للسرطان
ممكن مستقبلين حتى الان احنا
1723 حاله حتى اليوم
حالات جديده
ليس ببعيد عن المستشفى تستقبل هذه
الاستراحه اعدادا كبيره من مرضى السرطان
الذين لا يملكون ماوى في هذه المدينه اذ
يتم العمل على توفير الايواء والغذاء
بمجهودات شعبيه ودعم نوعي بسيط الاستراحه
على ضيقها هي الاخرى تعاني من ضغط المرضى
عندنا من التشات وعندنا من جنوب السودان
فداء ادى لتكدسهم وجود بالاستراحه يعني ما
بيقدروا يرجعوا اهلهم الا يطلقوا العلاج
وبرضو للاسف الشديد يعني تقطع العمليه تحت
العلاج انه العلاج ما متواصل او عدم توفر
العلاج في اوقات كثيره ادى لوجودهم هنا
داخل الاستراحه الصوره اشد قساوه مما هو
ظاهر على عدسه الكاميرا فقدرها هؤلاء
الذهاب باوجاعهم الى مكان امن وب بعيد عن
اصوات القذائف والرصاص لتلقي الجرعات على
ندرتها وي خوضون حربا لاستعاده العافيه
لاجسادهم وبلادهم كذلك التي تعاني من مرض
عضال يهدد بقاء الدوله بانسانها وهكذا
يقول البعض محمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه
ودمدني بولايه الجزيره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات